[Music]
let's go to st louis missouri and talk
to christy hey christy what's up
hey how are you dr john thank you for
taking my call i'm doing great thanks
for calling what's up
um i was calling uh because
i i'll start with the question that i
have
um
how do you know in your marriage um when
someone else has checked out and you um
you are holding it together but
they're gone
and so i'll give you the like baxter
right now um
i
my husband and i have been married 20
years and
we had a great dating relationship um
just like doing fun stuff like totally
active like hiking and
caving and
catching
lightning bugs and just just all kinds
of fun stuff shortly into our marriage
um we had what i didn't realize was a
communication problem
and so i'm extroverted i talk a lot
and um he's introverted and i think he
really likes the social outlet in that
um he can go places with me and i take
the social pressure off and he can
engage with people
and um
not not have all that pressure and so um
we've we've had a lot of
outside um problems with our marriage
just as far as we've had deployments
started a business we've had court
battles we've had a sick child who was
in the hospital for
um
it was it could have been terminal and
it um lasted for years his condition
which is now better and so um
we we have been through a lot together
um we started a business eight years ago
where he did it was his baby and
um i'm all in like
i i like to do the people side of things
and
i'm good at integrating so i've been
helping with the business and um just
over the last
well
to add a little more drama to our life
that business is going so well so why
not expand and start another so we have
another one in a different part of the
country and so
um
i would say this communication problem
has just grown and grown
and he doesn't really
want to hear me talk
so
um
he's he's okay by himself he's really
smart he's well read he um
he sets back and analyzes people and um
situations he's very discerning um if he
misses the mark on discernment
the
um verdict is already
sealed like you know
but
um
just
i mean he is my best friend so just over
the last
i don't know maybe 10 years it's just
gotten worse and worse we have five boys
and um
uh
they work in our business our family
works in our business our friends and so
he told me like six weeks ago and this
isn't the first time that he's leaving
and
um i feel like
i could
um talk him into counseling um because
he's agreed to that and maybe somehow
kind of guilt him interesting
but i can tell he's checked out
i'm sorry
thanks i hate that
saying that out loud hard huh
um when he told you he's leaving what
was the context there
it's really funny um yeah it sounds
hilarious christy
so
it um it was over a nice chest but i
know that that it's not over an ice
chest
um
for him i can tell you from his side
what it feels like is a respect issue
that if if i had enough respect i would
just be quiet
so um what i would tell you is you are
married to a very bold immature child
and that's probably the last thing you
think
and if he was sitting here i would tell
him the same thing that i love him
but the way he's chosen to handle the
world is to take his ball and go home
and if anybody doesn't want to play with
the rules that he set up for the game
then they i'm just going to cut them out
of my life
which you're free to do but it's what
children do
yeah adults especially adults in
committed relationships sit down and say
hey i made a judgment about a thing and
i may be wrong or my judgment may be
right
but my response to that judgment is
killing me
and it's killing the people that i love
so i'm gonna i'm gonna do some different
things i wanna do some different things
together
and my guess is whether he saw stuff
overseas or people deal with drama
differently people deal with heartache
and heartbreak and stress and trauma
differently
um
there's a little nine-year-old kid
inside or a little 14 year old boy
inside that's been at war for a long
long time who's just exhausted
yeah
and
it feels like he's been pulling a plow
for a long long time i'm just gonna quit
pulling the plow
so to answer your original question how
do you know when somebody's checked out
you know when somebody's checked out
all right that's not really the question
sounds like your question is what am i
supposed to do now
right
and my guess is you have been
you've heard me say this before
you've been sharing a bed with a guy
where you've been two inches apart from
him but y'all have been 5 000 miles away
from each other for a long long time
yeah and the question is do y'all want
to
put on your explorer hats and your snow
boots and
go on a great adventure to re-connect
over a long bridge that y'all got to
build on the way
are y'all going to go your separate ways
right
and the unfortunate part is you can claw
and climb and walk halfway through
siberia
but the other person's got to make that
journey on their side
right
and guilt will get somebody so far but
there's it doesn't get them all over
there right
yeah
um
i don't think it's a communication
problem i think there's probably
communication problems
but christy you haven't liked him for a
long time either
you haven't i tried to i don't agree
with myself i know but you haven't
and
both of you innately feel that the other
person doesn't like them so you create
with these worlds that y'all can both
inhabit and still share a bed together
and that so's that's the that's the
first seed in the soil for we got to do
some we're gonna do something else with
other people because this is gonna work
yeah
and you don't like him because of fill
in the blank and he doesn't like not
being liked so he ends up doing more of
fill in the blank and now we're off into
a dance that you wake up 10 years later
like i know you are
yeah
or i wanted you to grieve our kid in the
hospital like this and you just went off
and did this and i didn't think you
really cared well i didn't somebody had
to and now all of a sudden we've
started another dance
so you started the whole call so here's
the only path forward okay and i don't
say this dramatically this is this this
is your single shot okay okay i will
tell you this i have high high hopes for
your marriage
high hopes
i had a similar situation different but
similar
five years ago four years ago
where my wife and i sat down and said
we've got to make a hard choice right
now and if we're going to stick in it
this is what it's going to take and both
of us double down and it's i will tell
you now on the other side of that it's
like
i'm pretty arrogant i don't know a lot
of people who are in the situation i'm
in my marriage it's pretty good
okay
that's great that's pretty good
congratulations yeah exactly yes
thanks idiot
what an ass thanks delony right
so yeah that's great i'm just trying to
give you a light at the end of the
tunnel here
okay i love it when you started this
call
you started this call by telling me how
much fun y'all used to have
yes
that season is over
and the more you try to make in the
present what used to be
the more you hold up an impossible
mirror to you and your husband we don't
look like that anymore we don't look
like it's like the 40 year old woman who
doesn't look like she's 18 anymore of
course not
because she's 40 it's different now
and by
not looking at the 40 year old in the
mirror and seeing how beautiful and
stunning and wild and courageous and
full of scars and adventures she is
it's just all well you're not 18 anymore
that's not 18. you see what i'm saying
that's what you're doing with your
marriage
and so the only path forward
is both of you sitting down and saying
okay and you've heard me say this a
thousand times i'll say it a million
times more
the twin towers got knocked down
and we can never sweep up all that glass
and steel and dust
and rebuild the towers with those same
ingredients it's over it's gone
we have to excavate everything and
decide today we're going to build
something completely new
what is that going to look like
and in my house it was i need this from
you
i need this i need this i need this and
then my wife was like i need this and
this and this and i said i will go all
in on those things
and i will trust that you will go all in
on the other
but you got to build something looking
to the future not trying to reclaim
something from the past because a past
doesn't exist anymore it's a different
time in a different place in a different
planet
sure
you know what i mean
my question to you is do you like this
guy enough to do that
yes will you
yeah definitely
if he sat down with you and said all
right here's what i need
we're 42 years old i want
crazy rambunctious sex
and i want us to once a month go on a
trip together and i want you to stop
talking about work and also can we just
watch romantic comedies because i know
he's super into those
and can we not right whatever the thing
is and you vice versa
saying
what i really need is when you get home
you're off the phone and you're just
going to talk to me you know what my one
of the things my wife needed we call it
chit chat
i don't even know what that is really
except
when she's in the kitchen i sit up at
the bar
and we just talk about stuff
and there's sometimes i think i don't
know what we're doing right now she's
just chopping vegetables doing some
stuff looking at stuff but we're just
talking about things
and that makes her soul quiet it gives
her peace
i don't understand it but i'm all in
and now i've grown to love chitchat time
i don't even know what we're doing right
that's great you see what i'm saying
yes you don't have it doesn't have to
over complicate it it's just here's what
i need right now and then here's the
cool part and the annoying part
in three years your needs will be all
different again
and this will become a part of the
rhythm of your life is what do you need
in this season what do you need in this
season
and the adventure is not i got to get
all my needs met the adventure is dude
i'm going to
go over the top to meet your needs
because you're going over the top to
meet mine
i'm going to do i'm
i'm going to meet all of your needs so
that you can meet mine
it sounds transactional but it's not
it's deepening this thing
but it starts with sitting it down
saying okay the towers fell over
are you in this to rebuild something new
with me
and here's where that's a scary
vulnerable conversation christy he may
say no
okay
he may say no
but he might say yes
is that fair
yeah yeah it really is and then a part
of the the path going forward is
like
new york city didn't just rebuild it
they had to go get experts right so you
may need a marriage counselor to teach
all how to
i say this my need out loud i
automatically feel angry and i don't
want to feel angry and when i feel angry
then you feel mad that i'm angry
and they'll help you with some of the
dances right it's just a therapist is a
dance coach i'ma teach you all how to
interact with each other and move
throughout your day a little bit
differently
but i got real high hopes if we sit down
and have that conversation
okay and he's gonna have to agree
i'm gonna act like an adult moving
forward i'm not going to take my ball
and just go home every time
yeah
what if the answer is vague i mean do i
read it into it or do i just take it as
a no what is that say one more time
what if the answer is vague and do i
just read into it no no no no no you're
that's the communication issue both of
you are getting into each other's heads
fundamental attribution error they call
it in the nerd world i'm going to get
into your head and think why you just
did what you just did and i'm going to
judge you based on what i just why i
think you did what you just did
okay get out of each other's heads if
the answer's vague
we don't do vague anymore your
relationship doesn't have time for vague
right
right vague is a a screen in front of
your oxygen mask i don't got time for
that i need oxygen now
yeah
the question is
will you build something new with me
because if you're in it starts tomorrow
at 5 00 a.m
okay we're gonna go go for a walk and
maybe you do the hard work um and say up
front and say here's three things i need
okay and here's three things i'm willing
to do
and by the way christy as someone who
talks a lot i'm a lot
you know what i mean
so when my wife needs quiet time i
understand it because i'm a lot
i don't feel like i am but everyone's
look on their face around me assures me
that i am
okay
so some of that i have to go deal with
my own counseling i got to figure out my
own stuff because i bring a lot of my
stuff and you're gonna have to do that
too okay
okay
but
um the whole thing the whole enterprise
here's a risk
i think you're worth the risk i think
he's worth the risk i think 20 years in
your fight boys are worth the risk
i think all of it is worth the risk and
the beauty on the other side of this
thing can be something unimaginable
yes i believe that
okay
there can't be any more hedging from
this point forward
okay
okay you can't go halfway you can't have
sort of a talk you can't have a vague
talk you got to go all in
okay is that cool
yeah you let me know how that goes
i sure will thank you cool oh by the way
i called him a child you're kind of one
too right is that fair
probably 100 100
so
let's have a we'll have a grown-up
conversation hey will you let me know
how the conversation goes
absolutely okay i'll be thinking about
you guys man i uh i want the best for
y'all
and
to everybody who's in a relationship
who's struggling right now
who's wondering
that next
habit
conflict delayed is conflict amplified
it'll just get more have it
sit down and say i miss you i want to
build something new